Fair.
Well,
sweet cookie cats.
Always remember the time we spent together.
Hush.
Now
are you crying
by my friends?
Go Away.
They never will.
Oh,
I'm going to disappear without ever making a single friend.
Come on
guys,
please stop fighting.
I love to eat oatmeal.
I sincerely hope nothing happens to
dancing.
I'm
not strong enough to do anything.
Just once.
I'd like to burn him back
that night.
I really thought
player two is that just your way of saying I could have been anyone?
This isn't you.
You're not amongst already more.
You have to remember this all happened today.
You saved me with this.
You're going to get hurt.
We could ever find the way under all this.
Are you okay?
Keep going.
Please.
Let me be a magic healer.
Oh,
come on.
If I don't have powers,
then I can hang out with them at this or garden.
Eh,
now what if I can't do anything?
Stay tuned for another episode of crime.
Breakfast,
friends.
I wanted to see you guys acting like friends.
What if I never get back home?
Do you ever get lonely when you're around people?
Oh,
PT,
PT.
You got to look at the big picture here.
Oh,
it hurts.
No,
give back the gym.
My precious.
I thought I'd never see you again.
Daddy.
Come on.
We got open up.
I should have listened to you.
Please tell me what's going to happen with my lunch too.
I choke on a pig.
Oh,
master of ceremonies.
Bear bear.
I never asked to be made amethyst.
Amethyst,
please.
No more.
I know you're upset,
but I can't bear to watch you two already.
Each other.
You want to pretend that none of this ever happened.
You think I'm just a big mistake.
I hope you can forgive me.
You're the one good thing that came out of this mess.
I always thought you were proud of that.
Return to us.
The Emison Satie.
Oh,
Herve,
you bed all these years.
Is She okay?
I think you're pretty great.
I like
you.
You're welcome.
We did everything.
We could
turn the van around.
I have to go back.
I have to.
They don't have my shield.
You do.
You understand?
Yeah.
Okay.
Just be careful.
I'm going to run fresh out of family,
but this is my own.
I do
don't want to be friends anymore.
I still want to be friends.
You're ungrounded from TV.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Sometimes I get caught up in the drama zone.
You know
us
never love again.
Put Pearl to two whole weeks to come back and I already missed you at this so
much.
Oh,
okay.
Hey,
I mean rose made me feel like I was everything.
Five may beach city.
Oh ha ha ha.
These were crystal gems shattered into pieces.
They baby together.
I'm sorry.
Why are you crying?
Why are we going to make this work?
Okay.
Cry Bro.
Why did you lie to me?
I did
garden.
That's enough.
Please
pick your not as a bump.
This,
this.
Yes.
It's okay pal.
No wonder.
I don't
honestly think I'm not upset about what happened.
That's so beautiful.
Oh,
buddy was,
Dale does get to the end.
I'm just a pearl.
I'm useless on my own.
I need someone to tell me what to do.
I understand.
I can't give up anymore.
Ah,
just can't believe my little boys growing up so quickly.
Okay.
Power means nothing to Stephen's microscopic.
He's reverted back to a Zygote.
You're back to normal roadies work behind the scenes to make all magic on stage
possible.
It's isn't it?
Why can't buy move
both of you.
You know rose,
she did what she wanted.
I know you both needed,
just wanted the baby together.
Steven,
for your blog.
Cheap beach cities.
What are we going to do?
I'm full of sadness.
Just hold on.
I'll come home her.
You know I can't take it when you cry like that.
I'm sorry.
No,
no need to apologize.
This myth,
I can't use this.
I'm sorry business,
but it's not right.
I'm going to tell them.
I'm going to tell them everything
and you really better than her,
so stop leaving me out of this as worst gem stick together.
Right.
That's why we're the best
jasper such devotion.
Yes,
of course.
Rose Quartz would never do that.
It sure she had to fight,
but
I don't want to hurt you when I see the way you were wondering when I'm coming
back and I could do about anything.
I could even learn.
This will be the last thing I ever see as I expire.
Do,
I'm sorry.
I should know.
It's okay.
It's okay to think about it.
No,
Steven.
I did.
None of them will be helped them.
I had no choice.
It's okay.
It's not,
don't want to feel this way.
You have to,
you have to be honest about how bad it feels,
so you can move on.
That's how it was for me.
Okay.
Yeah.